I'm going to be talking about how we
actually implemented data contracts in
our analytics events system talk a
little bit about the why and get
probably too detailed about the how
um so really quick oh that's not working
um before I do that maybe just a little
bit of business context around uh
whatnot and our startup and what we do
so we are a Marketplace company an
e-commerce company
um our big Flagship feature is live
stream shopping uh you can see from the
video here the way it works is you
download our app you go join a live
stream there will be a seller who is
broadcasting usually themselves live and
they're selling something and you as a
user you can buy whatever it is they're
selling there are a few different
formats but typically uh you usually buy
from them via an auction so this is the
end of an auction and this is what
you're seeing here
um we typically sell in collectible and
Community Driven marketplaces like
sneakers and sports cards and Funko pops
and comic books and stuff like that uh
there are lots and lots of categories I
couldn't possibly name them all now
um and we were named the fastest growing
Marketplace in the United States for uh
I think two years in a row now so that's
pretty cool
um so that's like the one minute
business context of what uh well what
not is
um now I can do the one minute uh the
road so far with our data stack
um first of all quick plug for our blog
we write quite a lot about all this
stuff so go check that out there will be
another post about this probably uh in a
little bit
um
you know the tools in our data stack
Usual Suspects we use uh we use
snowflake for our data warehouse mostly
in AWS shop we use dagster for
orchestration uh we use DBT for
transformations in the warehouse and uh
segment and Kafka are the two that I'm
going to be talking about really
specifically today that's how we do
events uh and analytics events so when
an engineer is building a feature and
they want to log things happening users
tapping on certain things or users
placing orders that kind of event that's
what we're going to be talking about
um just some context uh on on the data
stack itself I think whatnot's kind of
unique we uh we started the data stack
around two years ago the company was
about 20 employees at the time
um we're I think the figure's a little
off we're like somewhere between 350 and
400 employees now just two years later
so we have seen an insane amount of
growth over a very short period of time
uh and growth is great it's been very
good but also uh it is not without
issues which is kind of what we're going
to be talking about so this graph on the
right hand side there's no y-axis so
it's not super useful but you can take
my word for it this is the the total
number of events that we've seen come
through our uh our event system over the
past couple years and you can see the
growth has just been massive uh we have
seen an explosion in the number of
events that are coming through our event
system and so uh yeah let's let's talk
about kind of what happens when when you
do that when you see this this kind of
growth
um so there's some problems uh the first
problem is that it kind of turns into
the wild west uh imagine you are a an
analyst and it's your first day at
whatnot and you get access to Snowflake
and you log in and you see that uh all
these different tables they're not
consistently named uh what exactly they
represent it's not super clear and it's
just a little bit chaotic
um so that's that's kind of a good
symptom I think for the first problem it
just creates this really tough user
experience where uh it's you need like a
very high level of context to know
what's going on here to like do your job
well so that's that's kind of the first
problem
um the uh the second problem uh is on
the event producer side we found
ourselves having a lot of the same
conversations over and over again where
Engineers uh you know we're a startup we
move exceptionally fast uh and when we
would ship new features we'd have a lot
of the same conversations oh we want to
build this thing how should we log for
it uh it's kind of like this feature and
so maybe we should log in a similar way
but it's a little different so maybe we
shouldn't and the problem with this kind
of conversation if you have it too much
is like it just slows everybody down and
like data consumers don't always end up
involved and it's kind of just a tough
situation
um so that's the second problem the
third I don't love the word ownership in
the context of data a lot of the time
but we kind of had an ownership problem
where uh software that emits events it's
just like any other software right like
it's gonna have bugs it's gonna be wrong
sometimes and when you notice those
issues it's important that you get them
fixed and in order to get things fixed
you need to be able to trace them down
to somebody who can fix them uh so that
was an issue that we noticed as well
um so yeah we saw we saw this happening
and we felt it was a very big issue so
uh we decided to do something about it
okay
um so I'm gonna start very high level
and then I'm gonna kind of go into the
into the weeds of what we did
um first thing we did is we made two
very big decisions the first big
decision we made is we are going to
unify all of our logging into one data
Highway you're either doing it the way
that we do it or you're not that was the
first big decision the second big
decision is uh we decided to come up
with a standard structured schema around
how you think about events uh this
format that we chose was actor action
object like user placed order or system
sent push notifications something like
that and that helps a lot right because
it just accelerates conversations of
when you're trying to do new things you
can do them you can do them quickly it's
not meant for 100 Precision there will
always be things that kind of snake
around that are a little different but
it it speeds up a lot
um so I'm actually going to go to the
next slide because there's there's four
components what I've described now are
sort of requirements and high level
system things uh they're not technical
decisions so uh how do you how do you go
about implementing something like this
uh well uh let me talk about it over the
diagram I think that'll be a little bit
easier
so what we have here is we have like a
pretty typical architecture of like a
data pipeline system right on the left
hand side we have
um we have event producers in the middle
we have pipelines that sort of move data
from one place to another and on the
right hand side we have event consumers
we just have snowflake in here for now
as our event consumers in real life we
have more than that but it's easy to
just talk about it with it's just
snowflake
um
so this is so this is the the sort of
architecture of the system and I
mentioned there are four components that
we built that sort of fit into this the
first component is uh what we call
common libraries uh for the producers
that create a consistent interface
um what this means is that basically in
each of the event producers on the left
hand side we implemented uh a library
that allows the like it follows a common
protocol so that if you're an engineer
working in any of these repositories you
have the same experience right when
you're trying to emit analytics events
um so that's that's the first piece but
of course if we're having a common
Library what is it that we expect people
to do
um so that goes into the second piece
which is the shared schema that's that
piece there at the bottom so the the
shared schema is at the bottom uh we use
protobuf um and uh there's two
components to it the first is just
typical protobuf the the messages
themselves uh if you've not used
protobuf before it's just a data
definition language or an interface
definition language where you can
describe how
um structure of how data should look
and so that's the first component is you
just Define the protobuf messages the
second component is uh one of my
personal favorite things about the
system which is code generation where
you take that schema and you generate
code out of it and then that is how we
connect the second the second piece the
schema to the first piece which is the
the sort of common libraries that people
use so the expectation then is that we
uh we generate code based on this shared
schema we implement it in the producers
and the libraries that we've built in
that first step both expect and require
us to use that that code generation so
that's that's sort of how the step one
and step two talk together
um now the third thing that we Implement
here is that ingestion pipeline in the
middle that's probably the the least
exciting part of this it's just receives
data and makes sure it gets where it's
going
um and then the fourth piece uh which is
also a little interesting is what we
call the exposure and the exposure is
just sort of you can think of it as the
downstream API that we expect consumers
to use we don't expose just raw data for
everybody to use most of the time at
least what we do instead is we put a
light sort of process layer in front of
it and that's what we expect consumers
to use and that um yeah and that's
that's the exposure
okay this talk has been very high level
and very architecturally and that was
not my intention so I think it would be
very helpful if we go through an example
and while some of these ideas are are
high level and Abstract if you actually
go like once you kind of have them
settled implementing this and operating
within it in practice is actually not
too bad
um so I think we can just walk through
an example and you can kind of see in
practice what what it ends up uh what it
ends up looking and feeling like so uh
yeah let's say we want to implement an
analytics event for when a user follows
another user just typical uh social
network functionality right I want to
follow another user on the app
so uh there's three steps to follow the
first step is we declare a schema uh you
can see here we have a protobuf message
as uh the the top thing uh notice it
follows that actor action object
framework that I mentioned uh at the
beginning user followed user
um it has some information just IDs
um one thing that we require people to
do is attach metadata to all of this
information descriptions uh like so we
know what this event means
um and then a team owner we attach to
each event as well so this is this is
step one uh the second part of this
first step is um we take this event and
we generate code out of it and once you
have this code you can move on to step
two which is you implement the producer
this is that client library that I was
talking to you about earlier
um you can see here sort of in the
middle I don't think I have a pointer
but um the user followed user event
right there in the in the code that is
the the object that has been generated
from the schema itself and that gives us
all kind of benefits like if the typing
is wrong and stuff like that then it the
the code itself here won't work
um so that is uh that is one of the big
benefits that we like about the system
um yeah and so this is this is the step
two the step two that we expect our
event producers to go through and uh
once they implement it in wherever uh
where they want we'll talk about testing
in a second uh as well um they're pretty
much done so if you remember from that
earlier slide uh we had all of those
different tables and all this different
stuff going on the exposure layer that
we have implemented uh consolidates all
this into two tables back-end events and
front-end events so we've really lowered
the amount of context that you need to
be able to jump into the system and
understand what's going on and uh just
some example queries that you can use to
sort of like get a sense of how uh how
how this data becomes much easier to
work with
um so yeah those are that's just a
concrete example
um just two quick things before before I
wrap up
um so there's uh as many of us I'm sure
know the real world is very messy and
things go wrong all the time so how do
we maintain quality and how do these
contracts actually end up in for like
getting enforced in the real world
um so there's a couple different places
the uh the first is uh we catch issues
before they even get implemented um when
you make that first pull request let me
see if I can go back here this one
um when you propose schema changes
there's all kinds of automated checks
that run in uh in the GitHub uh sorry on
your PR in the GitHub repo
um and it catches things like backwards
incompatible changes uh it catches
things like
um like improperly named Fields stuff
like that
um and so that's the first place before
we even Implement anything uh in the
second uh the second place where we
maintain quality is during development
as part of those common libraries uh
We've uh We've implemented sort of
testing harnesses that people can just
use freely to test their events and make
sure that they they work the way that
you expect them to so you don't just
have to blindly ship code you have like
a testing library that you can use to
make sure it's going to do what you want
it to do and then third again even even
with both of these these these two will
catch a lot of issues but you know the
real world anything can happen so uh we
have monitoring in Flight as well that
looks for particular exceptions and
we're we're uh we're trying out some of
the um some like in Warehouse monitoring
monitoring too where you can look at
anomaly checks and sort of like
distributions of certain events that
happen over time we're we're just
getting started there but we're working
more on it
um okay so that was a lot
um just want to talk a little bit about
learnings wrapping up here
um the first thing is about code
Generation
Um cogeneration has been a huge like a
huge thing that is paid for itself over
and over again
um the real benefit that it gives you
like if you think about a lot of data
Engineers they'll spend a lot of their
time fixing little issues that have kind
of like crept their way into the data
and code generation can fix a lot of
those things because it makes it
exceedingly difficult to send data that
is not in the format that you would
expect to in the very first place so it
goes it kind of shifts the problem left
extremely far and it uh yeah and so I
think it helps a lot there
um the second is like this was a lot of
work and it it was uh we were lucky we
were early enough in our journey to to
be able to pull this off so if you're
thinking about implementing a system
like this recommend you start early
um and then finally is I think one of
the things that we uh that we uh really
benefited from uh is we're really close
to our users we're really close to uh
the event producers and the event uh
consumers
um and uh you know there are a lot of
problems that we that we faced when we
were building this thing and I think we
had the benefit of being able to talk to
them in kind of a closed loop and uh
yeah I think that helped us solve a lot
of issues really quickly being able to
talk with them a lot
um all right so that's uh all I got
thank you very much
[Music]